et
[Musique]
moi
oh
il y en a qui ont la chance de ne pas
avoir besoin de fusées pour aller jouer
dans l'espace
moi ça me plairait bien et regardez
qu'est ce que c'est cette planète ou
grise
[Musique]
on regarde là
et il avait sous spatiale il se dirige à
cette planète suivant le
[Musique]
il a ces engins modernes c'est pas
pratique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais pas comment se nomme cette
planète mais moi je l'appellerai un
poubelle
[Musique]
regardez
une montagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle est cette chose
ce alors créé deux chiens mais qu'est ce
que tu fais ici tu cherches
oui bien sûr au crochet qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
attention vous 2000 il y est bien
cette quinzaine c'est un véritable musée
des ordures des camions on y mange bien
sûr
[Musique]
mais sarko encore de garnir les boîtes
ou à tous il faut nettoyer tout ça et
les petits voient tous font la chaîne
pour brûler toutes les ordures regardez
petit petit la montagne de saleté
diminue et figurez-vous que sous le tas
d'ordures
on découvre de l'herbe et des fleurs
[Musique]
quoi encore des camions et ma parole il
n'y a que ça sur cette planète
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant ce sont des chauffeurs
comme chez nous je ne comprends plus
rien je me présente je viens de france
et moi des états unis mais où sommes
nous j'ai peur de comprendre aux pauvres
astronautes
le choc est dur pour eux et oui bonjour
la toile
bonjour la statue de la liberté
bonjour le muraille de chine
bonjour le kilimandjaro et oui bonjour
la tête
je vous connais mieux quand il prend pas
[Applaudissements]
au revoir à tous à tous et merci
[Musique]